we went behind the scenes of Marvel
Studios Avengers damage control oh my
gosh guys i'm anjali crochet and i'm
here at the void in new york and i just
had an opportunity to go through the VR
experience Marvel Studios Avengers
damage control and man I just got to be
an Avenger it was an experience of a
lifetime but you know what don't take my
word for it I had the opportunity to
talk to some of the creators behind this
amazing experience let me go I am here
with Dave from Marvel Studios and Ian
from ILM xlab so talk to me a little bit
about where this is set because it it
seems that this is after the events of
Marvel Studios Avengers in game
it is set after the events of endgame
and purposefully so I think when we were
developing this story it was very much
having a conversation around what are
the things that people have waited their
whole lives to do what are the things
people have lived their whole lives to
relive knowingly while the the
filmmakers were working on infinity or
an end game and knowing that fans are
gonna go oh man this is going to be a
fan favorite moment this is gonna be a
fan favorite moment let's let's make
sure we take a little bit of that and
bring it to life over here you start off
with this moment with princess Shuri at
a wakandan Outreach Center hello and
welcome to the wakandan International
Outreach Center when we're looking at
developing the story for this it was
what are the things that make sense
we're gonna have a piece of technology
from the Marvel Universe designed by
Sheree set in a storyline post in game
who would Tony trust with his tech
probably the smartest person in the
Marvel Universe right and then having
Leticia right actually come back and
reprise the role it was a really good
way to make this authentic as well like
when you start out with something that
strong where you're going in and you're
like that is Sheree telling me that I'm
going to test her new prototype that's a
line in the sand saying that no you're
in this universe like get ready because
we're making this as authentic as
possible and on that authenticity the
same thing for that was also getting
other actors besides Leticia such as
like Benedict Cumberbatch
Paul Rudd and Evangeline Lilly to come
back and reprise their marble roles to
really bring this experience in a way
that really felt like you were stepping
into the movies as like with any good
novel story there's a few cameos when
you're fighting alongside the Avengers
anything can happen
a portal can open and take you anywhere
and anybody can show up and fight
alongside you one of the cool things
about this it's like unlike other VR
experiences that people have done before
you're not tethered there's no
controllers you're literally walking and
moving in this space yeah you actually
get to physically walk through the
experience you get you see a wall you
can touch it you see your friend you can
high-five each other you feel the heat
when something's warm around you the
ground will Rumble when they were big
huge explosions happen inside of it it's
on a whole different level when it comes
to that sense of immersiveness I think
that immersiveness though goes beyond
just the idea of a physical wall or a
smell the immersiveness comes from the
idea that what I am doing is real I put
my hand out and I fire a repulsor blasts
you really did that you cannot do that
if you choose to do that and that's the
fun of it right that immersion is now so
deep because of what the technology up
provides and what eylem xlab allows us
to do with our characters so for those
who are now just as excited as I am to
now go back through the experience how
can folks learn more about this and
where can they experience it yeah they
can go on the void calm and get tickets
it's here till November 10th at the
oculus in New York it's at other
locations around North America for a few
weeks after that
so hopefully fans can get out and get
haven't experienced it guys that was
amazing was it that was amazed at how
amazing like I want to go do it again
like right now let's go do it again
right now okay
you